I've heard things that are just horrid
about Vegas and the 80s how they had
cameras in room well Vegas in the 80s
was all mob Vegas and the bathrooms have
cameras so as long as you do a blast you
come out within 10 minutes the cops
around here when did they um when did
the mob like officially get out of Vegas
like what a mob is still in Vegas just
shorts birthed it's crazy I was in New
York last week and I realized how much
construction was going on and I thought
to myself how much of that is the mob
still getting they had a tax for years
2% so if it's a 300 million dollar job
do the math on that you make it a big
chunk on that show you know chunk didn't
get rich because the construction
business is huge and you go to New York
you know I can't give you accurate
numbers cuz I don't know numbers are but
look what the average is for a square
foot of concrete in New York
look what the average is in Iowa I was
reading something about that the square
foot of Carter to build a building in
New York st. the concrete is [ __ ]
insane because so many hands are getting
[ __ ] greased you know you don't pay a
job okay so you don't pay it's like that
one episode of The Sopranos so what I do
is break your balls you're a GC you
don't want to pay me my money that's
fine I send somebody from the Union down
there and instead of me doing this come
on through I gotta stop you I gotta take
your book I gotta call the union's to
see if you're paying up when you dues we
check your tire pressure we count the
low let's count the windows on the truck
recently you have 30 trucks backed up
and you're not making any money that's
how they'd shake you down that's the
shame then all you pay me okay the
trucks go through don't weigh one what's
on them we don't care who the driver is
we don't care fees you done Union it's
such a dirty business at that level
that's the shade down you jump would be
the GC on the job you pay your job run
smooth you don't pay so 2% of it went to
the moms at the concrete tax then they
had like another two
percent right off the top to bid rid bid
rate big rig bid rigging where we take
the G we give it to Joe Rogan no matter
what the price is we inflate the price
even though Jamie comes in three million
dollars cheaper I'm gonna give Joe Rogan
that three and two more Joe Rogan's
gonna kick that to to me then we're
gonna do the job at that's three million
dollar profit plus I'm gonna take 2% at
the top of that three million dollar
profit